it's like the best time to start a
business and start doing anything that
you can because you have time and you
don't have there's not much downside so
like in college i started like a
discount card business i started a
consulting business i started a
craigslist for college students most of
these things failed but i think
especially early on take a lot of risks
as many risks as you can because you get
older we get boring and we get safe and
we get scared of losing and and i think
especially when there's less to lose go
out there and be bold hey friends
welcome back to deep dive if you're new
here my name is ali and in each episode
i chat to authors entrepreneurs creators
and other inspiring people about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that we can learn
from them to apply to our shared journey
of trying to live our best lives this
episode is a little bit different it is
part of the off season between season
two and 3 of the podcast and this is
actually an interview that i did with my
friend noah kagan from way back in 2020
before the official launch of this
podcast noah is one of the most
inspiring entrepreneurs that i know he
started out as employee number 30 at
facebook before getting fired by mark
zuckerberg and we kind of go into that
story which is kind of interesting he
was then employee number four at mint
which became a ridiculously successful
company and he's now the ceo of the sumo
group of apps which is itself an
eight-figure business noah is also
writing a book about entrepreneurship
and he and he shares loads of really
interesting things about
entrepreneurship and business and stuff
like that on his own youtube channel
which will be linked down below in the
conversation we discuss a bunch of
things including what he learned from
being fired by mark zuckerberg at
facebook we talk about how he actually
went about building this eight figure
business and how it's all working now
and we talk about some of the things
that you can do to get a head start on
your career so i hope you enjoy this
throwback interview with noah kagan
let's go for it no welcome to the
channel how's it going
it's going great i'm super excited to
talk with you yeah man this is gonna be
fun i wonder if we could start by if you
could just talk through how your career
has gone so far i guess from leaving
school what you've done and maybe we can
talk about lessons that we learned along
the way and then we'll dive into more
productivity and talk about some of the
books that we enjoy i know you're a fan
of a million miles in a thousand years
which i read like two days ago and it
made me cry so many times so yeah
definitely i'm never excited about that
yeah
yeah man it's uh it's been a journey and
i'm curious for you to share your
journey as well i don't know which parts
you haven't shared with your audience my
journey when i graduated college i went
to uc berkeley i i didn't know what a ba
or bs was
i guess people bachelors of science and
i was like i don't really know i just
knew that in college number one i was
like super active doing things in
college
and i just knew that i've always loved
technology and i love computers and i
love sales and those things and so
i think college especially i know that's
a lot of your audience it's like the
best time to start a business and start
doing anything that you can because you
have time and you don't have there's not
much downside so like in college i
started like a discount card business i
started a consulting business called hfg
consulting i started a craigslist for
college students called collegeup.org
most of these things failed but i think
especially early on take a lot of risks
as many risks as you can because you get
older we get boring and we get safe and
we get scared of losing like i'm like i
don't want to lose my money and and i
think especially when there's less to
lose it's like go out there and be bold
yeah like i think so
for me i started my entrepreneur journey
when i was i guess in america you would
call it middle school i think i i was
around 12 at the time and i taught
myself how to code by following
tutorials on w3schools and things like
that and then i started freelancing my
services out on rentacode.com and i
would try and undercut the market
because i was just a kid i could you
know get by with five dollars for a
project and even so like the indians
would still manage to undercut me and i
was like why how is this happening and
so that was how i got my start and
through middle school we called it
secondary school in the uk every year me
and my friends we would come up with a
new business idea and every year they
all failed but we learned a lot from
each kind of iteration of those business
ideas and so for me like when i got when
i was in my first year of med school
that was when the next business i
started started to do well just one
thing to highlight so literally this
morning and starting last night i made a
list of every business i've ever started
oh and it's over 20. and so i finally
i'm worth over a million dollars and
it's not bragging and i just want to
give people context but that's after 20
years of trying over 20 different
businesses and i think when i was
younger i was like i'm not a millionaire
by the time i was 30. i we had this idea
called 30 by 30. when i had 30 million
dollars by 30.
and it's tough
and i didn't realize how many things
i've been doing
until i finally got became a millionaire
and so i call it the 10-year rule so if
you can find something and work on it
for 10 years you will become a
millionaire if that's your goal or if
you're trying to be a musician or if
you're trying to be an artist or if
you're trying to be a writer as long as
you do 10 years of it you'll get
whatever level of success you want but i
i just didn't realize how long it does
take and even for yourself i think one
thing that you said that i want to
highlight that's so great is
you solved your own problems hey i'm
good at this web stuff hey i'm good at
this medical stuff and especially in
college and when you're young just get
started right now
yeah absolutely that's the classic
advice i give everyone that it's so easy
to spend so much time thinking and
reading and stuff
but getting started is like is it is you
know the first step i wonder if you can
tell the story of how how was your time
at facebook like employee number 30
that's pretty early on isn't it i mean i
think they're around 50 000 employees
now so yeah i would say like i was
literally just in a previous
conversation mark hated when you
hyperlinked periods
and he had a really he was really
interesting this is a guy that at 21 or
22 i was there and yahoo offered us a
billion dollars
oh so ali if i offered you a billion
dollars to never youtube again drop out
of medical school and then you have to
start a new career right now what are
you going to do
oh that would be tricky i'd probably
take it to be honest a billion is a lot
oh yeah it's quite a lot i would
definitely take it and figure out
something else to do with my life i
think one of the things that people
don't appreciate enough about mark is
that he's had to make good decisions for
20 years
great decisions
for six it's been around since 2004 for
16 years anyone could have a company for
one year do well but for 16 and so i
think what mark did well and what was
interesting about that experience i
started saying earlier
he would notice on a help page if a
period was linked
and he would fix it or he would tell the
team you need to fix it and so i think
his attention to detail was unparalleled
but i think something that's even more
important that wasn't that's not really
talked about or recognized from mark
he had a vision that was so appealing
and so big that we i dedicated my life
to working there and i think that's
what's missed in a lot of com people
trying to start businesses or some of
these companies not doing as well mark
said we are going to connect every
single person in the world
and he did yeah but he said that in 2005
and he said that when he rejected a
billion dollar offer
and
that says a lot about what he was trying
to accomplish and you know i think
there's something there when
what do the people do when they already
have so much money they don't have to
work anymore and so what i always
encourage people is how do you just do
that work now
like it's so obvious that you love
making youtube videos
i don't know maybe you're in like you
secretly hate me when i watch your
videos
i'm like this guy
is not it's not natural because you're
putting in the work which i think people
don't realize but you're enjoying it and
i think there's something there but find
the thing that you do if you have a
million dollars in the bank and guess
what by doing that you'll actually get
the million dollars in the bank
yeah
this is actually something that i've
been asking a lot of doctors and medical
students for the last kind of six years
since i got into medical is that if you
won the lottery would you still want to
be a doctor and
the story that i tell is that like of in
the past like i actually i think it's
yeah in in the past eight years of
asking this question about half of the
people have said they would leave
medicine completely and the other half
have said they would still do it because
it's fun but they would go part-time
and then the next question is okay why
don't you go part-time from today and
the answer is always what i've got bills
to pay i've got the mortgage and stuff
and so like from very early on i was
like okay this is the the future that i
want to avoid i don't want to be in this
position where i've done this six years
of med school i've done all these years
of training and i'm now a doctor my
answer to that if you won the lottery
question would be something different to
exactly what i'm doing now and so that
was the thought process that started me
on this path of trying to set up
businesses and passive income and
financial independence and all that kind
of stuff because medicine is fun but i
don't think anything is fun if you do it
full time and so that's the future i'm
trying to mitigate against would you
rather do youtube full-time or medical
full-time if you had to choose
uh if if i could only choose one
probably youtube full-time just because
you get a lot more freedom but ideally
i'd like to do both kind of part-time i
don't think i'd want to do youtube
full-time i feel like it would lose some
of the charm if it becomes like a
full-time job
yeah i remember i was at a dinner party
in new york years ago and i met this
girl and i whenever i'm at meeting new
people i try to avoid asking what they
do i try to hold out as long as possible
i make it a game i try to i'm like oh
you're going to ask me you lose and so i
we ended up talking she's oh i'm an ice
cream maker
i was like oh that's such a cool job
cool career
and
i was like oh how much ice cream are you
eating a day and she's like i haven't
eaten ice cream in two years
and so
i thought there was something kind of an
interesting story in that which is
sometimes if you do something you love
so much you don't even end up liking it
so i think generally find the thing that
makes you money that you enjoy but also
keep these hobbies because for me the
hobbies
it keeps my stimulation going like i'm
into chess so you can play me chess.com
oh no yeah
we should totally have a game sometime
oh well my username is okay dork i don't
know if yours is
publicly yeah i think like
last time i had a session on chess.com
was i think in 2015 or something but
i'll have to check my account
i'll add you as a friend on that
so you were at facebook for a bit and
then
you left facebook and then you joined
mint after that is that was that the
trajectory
no i got fired oh okay
what was the story there if you're open
to talking about it because i wasn't
going to bring it up because i was like
this might be a bit of a sore spot but
it's good since you bring it up
no i think a few things so one i think
chips on shoulder create successful
people
i think if you have some like you have
to have some purpose so for me with this
whole coronavirus thing i have literally
felt compelled to help people start
businesses or do their marketing or i've
been calling myself a confidence
cheerleader because i'm so excited about
all the stuff happening for people that
want to do work like the action takers
and so i felt called into that with my
facebook experience specifically i i
think there's a different component a
few different things there but i don't
think i think that they were right to
fire me i think if i was mark and that
team i would have fired me too and it
created a chip on my shoulder that has
compelled me to go do others so i think
the thing there to think about because
it's not about my story what's the
lesson for you so i think the lesson for
you is a few different things number one
are you invaluable to the company not
everyone should run a business not
everyone should do youtube it's a lot
harder than it seems it's easy to watch
you put out a video but they don't see
the hours and the retakes and the cuts
and all the effort and the years to get
there so you don't have to run a
business but if you're going to go work
somewhere number one are you invaluable
meaning if they try to replace you today
how much would they be set back that's
number one
and number two i think if that's not the
case i think for everyone out there like
you've done ali which i commend you on
is how much are you creating control in
your life because what you've done is
you said hey if the medical thing
doesn't work out i control this income
from the abdul youtube channel and so
like that's why i try to encourage
people we put out a course it's seven
dollars uh called monthly1k.com which is
like hey if you want to do start a
business and get a little more control
in your life that's what i recommend we
also refund the money once you make it
back i don't want to make i don't want
to make any money from it but so the
thing with facebook again i think be
invaluable to the company and figure out
like all right if i can't control this
what things can i start doing to control
and i also i think at that time in my
life i had to mature
i wasn't mature enough to actually be
successful there and i think what's
interesting is what happens when your
identity gets taken from you yeah
that's it's really i remember the day i
was in a coffee shop matt kohler who's
now a billionaire and cere fired me at
this coffee shop in palo alto
i went my cell phone was a facebook cell
phone so they took that from me and so i
had to go to the store and buy a cell
phone
and then i bought a pack of cigarettes
and i lived in a house with all facebook
people
and so i went i went to the house packed
all my stuff out and i moved to my
friend's couch i used to work at intel
before that and i just moved into my
friend johnny's couch and smoked
cigarettes and i basically sulked
for a long period of time
how did you get yourself out of that so
i think with how to get out of that
number one you should sulk watch netflix
eight hours drink a little bit smoke a
little bit take just get depressed for a
bit and and the reason i say that ali
is that i think you have to hit rock
bottom before you can start coming up
and so how to start doing and so you're
like i had i was literally sleeping on a
couch didn't have a lot of money but all
of my friends worked at facebook
everyone knew i worked at facebook and i
just got fired and this is now public
so i think a few things happen number
one
you need to get your confidence back up
you need to feel self-worth so what i
did right there is just make your bed
okay so if you live if you're if you're
sleeping on a couch
fold the sheets oh okay actually i'm on
the corner
make your bed why because you can
control that i couldn't control facebook
removing me or not that was their
decision but i can control the bed i can
control the gym
so start even just doing a push-up
because guess what you need to do things
that give you confidence number three go
help one person
and so what i mean by that is look on
your phone or look in your network look
on linkedin or look at your schoolmates
or look at your teachers or look at your
parents or look at your religion and say
let me just reach out to someone and
help them for free
and i think when you start teaching like
you do with youtube or you help and you
realize you impact one person you start
realizing for yourself like i am worthy
the next thing that i would do there's
two other things i would do look at your
network
you have a bigger network everyone has
at least 500 friends
and
within those 500 friends someone
probably has someone that could help you
so look within your network and start
asking for help like i always tell
people to do the coffee challenge i
don't know if have you heard me talk
about what's the coffee challenge
so the coffee challenge is where you go
anywhere you buy something generally at
a cafe cafe and you ask for 10 off
oh yes i have heard you talk about oh i
remember one time you mentioned this on
a podcast and i broke out into a sweat
literally just thinking about it and i
was like oh my god what is wrong with me
yeah it's intense you ask for the 10 off
and your heart is like this yeah
and then
you get rejected
or maybe you get accepted
and then you realize you're still alive
and the reason i think that's i
literally think asking is one of the
most powerful muscles that anyone can
develop
and when you ask that's ultimately what
you're doing in almost everything in
life you're saying hey i'm asking for
this job i'm asking for this
relationship i'm asking for things and
the more that you can become overcome
fear
for practicing that things become easier
so start asking your network what you
could get help with one last thing that
i want to say that really helped me with
facebook after the facebook experience
there's a few more things but especially
if you're younger go and start
connecting people go and start building
up your audience so send fox.com is a
free newsletter that we created and it's
something that i just wanted and so what
20 years ago is in 2000 so it's when i
started blogging on okdor.com oh damn
that was a long time ago it was before
you were born i'll leave just kidding
but i started blogging and so i think
what's important there is that
start building up your brand start
building up your audience because no one
can take that away from you so start a
blog or you know on sundfox.com start a
newsletter and so i started doing that
and i started hosting events
so i actually just put on a conference
so i think the part there is look at
what you not just your network look at
what your special look what makes you
special and so for me i was like i
worked at facebook
that's pretty special there's only like
100 people that can say that at that
time so i said what if i put on a
conference
and what if i started hosting things
so i didn't have a big network i didn't
have any attention at that point but i
put on basically conferences where i hit
up these people and said hey i worked at
facebook would you mind coming and
speaking at this thing and so i did this
thing called entrepreneur27.org
where i just started putting on events
and then i promoted them and i started
doing that and then i did a thing called
communitynext.com which i just invited i
just asked people like guy kawasaki and
max levchin from paypal and the hot or
not guys
and i put on a conference and actually
ended up making fifty thousand dollars
because i wasn't trying to make any
money
and so the point that i'm saying there
is that i think especially if you're
just getting started
in your career
start building those relationships
because i can't tell you now like ramit
sethi or tim ferriss guy kawasaki a lot
of these guys i just helped promote them
and connect with them really early on
and if you're young people are way more
open uh to having you connect with them
nice yeah that's pretty great advice
occasionally i get people asking hey
what would you tell yourself kind of 10
years ago when i would have been like 15
at the time and honestly the thing that
i would tell myself is yeah you know
dude start a personal blog start writing
at the very least book reviews of all
the books that you're reading if you see
a good movie just write something about
it just to build up that habit of
writing and i really wish i'd been doing
this for so much longer than i have
because it's just such a superpower when
you have a blog that's 10 plus years old
and you can see the progression of posts
and you build the audience over time and
then like going back to all the business
stuff once you have a pre-existing
audience it's so much easier to do
everything than to start from scratch
it's much easier to garden than to hunt
garden then to hunt what do you mean by
that well a garden it takes time and you
have to plant a seed but then you get
this a lot of vegetables and it's
guaranteed it's right there in your
house but it takes time to actually get
that where a lot of us we just go out
and hunt and we're like oh i hope i find
something out there and i'm just going
to go ask for things right away and
you're going to hope for it right away
but you may not get it right away and so
i think that's what you were
highlighting is like start planting your
seeds now for things that you can enjoy
later yeah absolutely so we've got this
live blog going on the side and we've
got some questions in from the audience
if you're if you're up for it question
number one is from adam alvarez ali who
says how do you deal with feeling behind
in life career-wise is that anything
that you struggle with feeling behind i
suppose being fired from facebook is
pretty far behind most of your friends
at the time especially if you were
living with other facebook people
yeah
i i think everyone has a different label
for it i think some of the phrases i've
had two experiences one i was on the
streets of argentina
and i remember being in the center of
the street
thinking what am i doing with my life i
was 25
and i was like what is the purpose of
all this and i just felt really lost and
then recently in the past three years i
haven't really done a lot of work ali
i've actually felt really discouraged i
haven't i think the word that i think of
is not behind but unleashed
and i know tony robbins says unleash the
power within but i just think i don't
know i think it's have i found my
calling have i found my purpose and so
for adam
i i think the one thing i would do is
well i would actually do two things but
so number one look back what you did as
a kid that you just really enjoyed
was it reading was it bicycling was it
writing was it photography and then
number two look at what you've been
doing for in your spare time for free
and so
i think what we do is in our heart i
know this is going to be woo-woo so
i'm not a woo-woo person so just let me
put that out there but in our heart we
know man like for noah i love sharing
content i love talking with you i love
sharing different like things on like on
my youtube channel
or with appsumo i love this
but in my head i said
ah that's just another talking
influencer they're stupid that's never
tough you don't know anything noah you
actually like your stuff's not helpful
you're not enough
and i i did that for three years
and i think and that's our head kind of
fighting our heart
and yeah you're shaking your head
because you probably agree and we're
embarrassed because i i i thought about
i literally thought oh my high school
friends are going to watch you know the
noah kagan on youtube and they're going
to think oh he's stupid or look at he's
got pointy ears because i got pointy
ears oh yeah you did i do kind of like
spock and i'm self-conscious you know
i'm human i bleed real blood
but eventually you kind of when you go
into that heart
and you start really following your gut
and that that heart intuition
that is when you don't feel behind
so i i think that's number one thing i
would say for adam is just like really
listen to what you've been doing and go
back and revisit it revisit chess that
was important for me revisit sharing and
worrying about not less about everybody
else but just more about yourself the
second thing i think adam said is behind
yeah so to be behind
is that a comparison
and yeah it sounds like adam is
comparing himself to potentially his
peers to his peers and so i think
comparing is helpful right so jealous i
love jealousy
right because jealousy is a compass of
something that you either want or don't
want in life like i have a friend who
was making more millions than i was
which is it's ironic cause i still drive
a miata so i don't even use this money
but i think the idea is it's not about
where you're behind or not it's maybe
this is giving you clarity about what
you really want or where you want to be
and i always think of life as like a
google map
and what you do in a google map is you
try to have to really spend a lot of
time say where am i going
and then figuring out your route is
actually pretty easy
so i i would just think if you're behind
what i would encourage you to do is
instead of worrying so far ahead and
worrying about others maybe use jealousy
to compass figure out so it's now almost
may 1st
2020.
just decide where do i want to be at the
end of may 30th and what would make that
epic another thing that i've done
recently that's been honestly a game
changer
i made a list
in my day
of what makes my day fulfilled
okay interesting because i was like if
you think about it actually let me ask
you this what makes it for you a great
day versus just an okay day just riff
with me on it yeah okay so a great day
for me would be one where i get home
from work and i feel like i've
accomplished something at work i've had
good banter with the the nurses and the
other doctors and so there's been kind
of like a social element to it i think
the days that i enjoy less are the ones
where i'm just on my own in the doctor's
office doing paperwork because that's
just boring because there's not much
kind of human contact i think a day is
good when like often if i film the video
for the day or if i've done the things
that were on my to-do list then i think
oh yeah that was a good day and i can go
into bed crappy but on days where i kind
of procrastinate and just end up
scrolling through instagram i feel like
wasted my time what am i doing with my
life yeah one of the things that we can
highlight for adam is i have a thing
called gaby and something i put in there
but i think part of it is if you're
behind how can you just start out at
least your morning strong and i think
there's a lot of books that do it and
they're all maybe more complicated than
i want to consume so gabby to me is
basically what i do every single morning
and i'll show you some of it but it's
basically gratitude exercise breakfast
and you and i do this every single
morning i actually use strides app it's
a free app oh yes i had that downloaded
ages ago
oh i love strides basically it's like
every to-do that i do today i just it
basically is my gabby so it's like how
do i start my day off strong so i don't
feel behind so gratitude every morning i
write down one thing i'm grateful for
and i just put in my notes i don't do
any complicated app for that
so today i was grateful for my stepdad
and then yesterday i was grateful for a
piano and the day before i was grateful
for bathrooms just like funny stuff okay
and then exercise so i try to do 250 i
don't try i do 250 push-ups a day so
just what exercise are you going to do
so i use push fit okay it's a free app
and i just do a bunch of push-ups and so
i get some exercise in and this is what
helps me start my mornings and my days
great breakfast so today i had some
healthy blueberry stuff and you and so i
think part of you it sounds similar to
me which is what are you doing for
yourself today and you know that when
you do a video
you feel great and so that's what i was
kind of starting with that makes a day
fulfilled is
i think people especially young or old
we can be more intentional about how to
make a great [ __ ] day and so just
think about what makes a day great is it
a video for me this kind of conversation
i'm going to be glowing the whole rest
of the day on the point of this making
list of things that that fulfill you i
came across this in some blog posts like
last week and i just was like okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna take this seriously i
just kind of started writing down a list
of all the things in my life that i
really enjoy
and i kind of got about 20 things down
on the list and i realized that the
whole doctor side of it wasn't really on
the list it was more things like making
videos or listening to a particularly
good audiobook or playing board games
with friends or doing practice i'm
trying to teach myself music theory with
piano and guitar and stuff and those are
the things now that are bringing me more
fulfillment than my job and that was
another kind of signal in my head that
okay
maybe this
because i think one thing that i
sometimes struggle with is because
having gotten gone through so much of
medicine
the story in my mind is that if i were
to take a break from that potentially
then
i don't know i'd be throwing away all
this effort or i'd be stepping out into
the void
but in terms of the things that fulfill
me i think that was a helpful exercise
for me to realize that okay cool if i
could design my kind of ideal day these
are the things that would be in it and
so how can i work towards a future in
which that's possible what called you
into medicine to begin with then because
it seems is that yeah you have to
revisit that or is that in question now
i think so the thing that called me into
it was honestly i didn't really know
what else to do and when you're my
ethnicity and you get decent grades at
school like the default path is you just
do medicine i was like all right i might
as well do medicine i i was torn between
medicine and computer science because
i've been i've been doing the whole
coding thing and i'd been doing stuff in
php and i was like doing computer
science would be cool but when i was
making this decision at the age of 17 i
had the thought that
uh it would be much cooler to be a
doctor who can code than to be just a
coder and i also had the thought that
six years at university is more
interesting than three years at
university because they say that
university is the best time of your life
and so that was why i chose to do
medicine it wasn't really a calling as
such it was more like okay best option
i'm not really sure what to do let's
just go for it and i'm super glad that i
did i did the degree and the job is
quite fun but i don't think it's what i
want to do for the rest of my life at
least not full-time hence the whole kind
of youtube channel and all this other
kind of business stuff that i've been
trying to do and learning from you on
your podcast
so
how are you going to move forward with
that man that's a big thing because i
yeah from august i'm going to be
unemployed essentially because after two
years of being a doctor in the uk at
that point you then apply for a
residency program in whatever specialty
you want and i wasn't really sure what
specialty i want to go into
and i was from speaking to loads and
loads of consultants i senior doctors at
work
most of them were saying that look
there's no rush to get through the
training pathway the nice thing about a
medical career is that you can always
take a break and then you can come back
and you don't really lose anything and
so the plan before the whole virus
situation hit was that i wanted to spend
a year just kind of traveling the world
and doing that thing because i've never
really done solo travel i've been
listening to rolf potts's podcaster
deviates
and like all these interviews with
people like traveling the world and
traveling with with just one backpack
and i was thinking that would be a much
more interesting story and going to
donald miller's a million miles in a
thousand years that was what was going
through my mind i was like okay this
kind of crossroads that i'm at it's do i
go down this traditional path of being a
standard doctor or do i do something
more
more like adventurous and the more
interesting stories definitely i don't
know putting on a backpack and trying to
travel the world as cliche as that
sounds
so one thing you're a redditor too like
me you seem like you do read it i dabble
here and there
one of my favorite subreddits is it's
called one bag oh i haven't seen that
subreddit oh oh it's phenomenal so
basically you just go to reddit r slash
one bag and it's just people's one bags
and what they pack for this travels so i
think that it's super inspiring and you
see a lot of oh what's like the shorts
to wear like i like wearing like a
little lemon stuff because you can wear
it for a lot of days without smelling
yeah or these new little lemon shorts
they're pretty good nice
but i think that's interesting for you
man like that book that book changed my
life and we both talked about how we
cried from it it's one of my favorite
books all time is a thousand is it a
million miles in a thousand yeah i think
it's a million miles in a thousand years
yeah
yeah by donald miller and i think the
two things that stuck with me is to live
an interesting life
you just have to do interesting things
and i know that i hate when people say
stuff like that to me but that's such a
truism yeah
it's like you just and i think he's such
a and he's a christian author which i'm
i'm not a christian but i still love his
messages
uh and i think they're positive and i
think the second part about living
industry life is just to do interesting
things but the second part that's just
as powerful as
how do you just be around interesting
and some people might be geographically
limited like maybe the people are in
ohio or they're in you know some other
foreign country
and
the internet is a great way like i think
almost 80 percent of my best friends
i've met online
which used to sound sad but now it's
just like the thing everyone does
yeah you start making friends on twitter
and then you hang out in real life and
you're like oh we have so much in common
how about this dude like andrew warner
is actually he's listening and he runs
mixergy he is the reason appsumo
actually got started and i met him
because i was doing those conferences
and i think the beauty of just getting
going and starting with something
starting with your writing starting with
your photography starting with your
video is the relationships you get to
make the people you get to meet and for
me my blog i haven't made that much
money blogging like directly blogging
maybe a few thousand over 20 years but
the relationships and the fulfillment of
that is amazing
so one thing i'm curious just to come
back before the book and you traveling
the world what are you gonna tell your
parents because i'm wondering was it
your parents that were like you're gonna
do a doctor and you're gonna go do this
thing no not really actually so
my mom is a doctor but she never really
tried to push me into it she just
thought i would i'd be more likely to do
maths because i was a bit of a nerd and
nowadays what she says is that i i think
she's quite like a traditionalist she
says that look you can travel the world
and all that but finish your training
first and then do all that stuff later
on
whereas my theory is more that i'm
single at the moment i i'm not tied down
by kids or responsibilities as such i'm
traveling the world for a year when i'm
25 26 is unlikely to be something i'll
ever regret i'm not going to be on my
deathbed thinking ah damn i wish i was a
fully qualified doctor for one year
longer than i actually was i have a
friend i won't name him
it starts with a j
but you get trapped in work life you get
trapped and as you get older you start
making some money
and then you start having bills and then
you're like i want to do this thing but
i gotta pay the bills and i want to do
this thing and so i think especially
earlier on like you're doing is really
commendable and it's one of those things
that a lot of people say they want to do
afterwards and so one phrase for myself
and why i've been so more vocal on my
youtube channel and with my content on
my podcast and my email list is i think
it's really interesting the phrase that
goes in my head is called no apologies
and so i think for you it's the same
thing with the doctor piece yeah i'm a
doctor so i'm supposed to go to this
thing and i'm supposed to do this thing
we apologize to the world
yeah and we apologize to oh if i put out
this video i have to apologize and so i
think it's interesting for every single
person like tyrone or jake or tyler
naveen if we didn't have to apologize
for anything we did obviously don't kill
people or rob or do anything stupid
but my question is if you didn't have to
apologize and you could really just
follow your heart
that's not what i thought we'd be
talking about but
what would
what would you want to do and so for me
one of my my fantasy list this year is i
wanted to live in a van
oh okay yeah and so yesterday i rented a
van
and i'm gonna go live in a van for three
weeks oh and amazing
yeah man
and so i think
there's two things there which is number
one you got to have stuff to look
forward to in life
that's just something my me and my
friend adam gilbert from mybodytutor.com
we talk about that a lot what are you
looking forward to this week this
conversation was on my highlights for
sunday like on sunday i was like i'm
looking forward to talking with ali
so what are you looking forward to and
if you're not just go make something
look forward to it and the second thing
is have these fantasy lists
of things that you're like man i think
this would be an amazing adventure
because as especially get older it goes
fast someone asked me yesterday how old
i am
and i was like i don't it's i think i
feel in my 30s but technically i think
i'm 38 and it just keeps going and so in
this period of time we have a live it's
what things are really excited to go do
so i really i commend you because it's
hard to go against the grain
it's hard to be like saying hey i've
everyone else is going this way and olly
you're choosing to go left yeah that's
something i think about have you have
you come across the youtube channel uh
yes theory
no what is this oh it's amazing they
they would like it's a life-changing
youtube channel basically it's these
three guys that travel around the world
and their whole mantra is seek
discomfort like they would do insane
challenges like travel to a country and
without any money at all and rely on the
kindness of strangers to kind of get by
and have these amazing adventures from
going up to random people on the street
and kind of introducing themselves and
just kind of having a good time and they
i think last year they challenged will
smith to bungie jump off a helicopter
and he accepted their challenge and they
had this like massive like thing going
and their whole spiel is about this
thing of stepping outside your comfort
zone and that being where growth happens
and just super positive vibes i think
you'd really like it i'm gonna check it
out two things two things there is
number one what's one thing
uncomfortable or discomfort or action
you could do for yourself today
and i want the audience to comment on
some of those things the second thing
and i'm curious for you in our lifetimes
i think it's really fascinating what
we're most proud of
and when we've grown the most
again what are we most proud of
and when have we grown the most and so
i'm curious for that so it's one thing
to do but for only for yourself like
what are you most proud of so far in
your life and when have you grown the
most and and i think there's a point to
both of these i'll go afterwards okay so
we'll i think we're getting some answers
in from the audience so for me
i think the thing i'm most proud of is
probably
the youtube channel because it was the
thing that's
been the most kind of difficult in in
inverted commas and just the amount of
grind that it takes over a very long
period of time and at the start you're
shouting into the void and no one's
listening but over time the as the
flywheel turns it starts to gain
momentum and so
seeing how i don't know like proud is an
interesting word that i don't often use
because it sort of implies
that it's it's surprising i'm taking
credit for the thing that's happened
whereas i know it's mostly down to luck
and privilege and circumstances and i've
just tried to not squander the good hand
that i was dealt but i'd probably say
the youtube channel
and then when do you think you've grown
the most that's a good question
honestly so
there was one experience i had a few
years ago where so every year at the
medical school at cambridge we put on a
pantomime and sell tickets and and all
this sort of stuff and i was involved in
the pantomime in my fourth year of med
school i was part of the singing troupe
but then in my fifth year i got a random
message from a guy saying that hey ali
i'm going to be directing the pantomime
this year would you like to direct the
show with me and i had no acting
experience no theater experience like i
knew nothing about theater in the
slightest i thought that this is like a
an amazing opportunity to
step massively outside of my comfort
zone and so i said yes to that and this
guy was amazing like he was something he
was he's been into theater for years and
like knew what he was doing and i very
much had imposter syndrome like i had no
idea what was going on but through that
i think the main thing that i learned
honestly is that i was so worried at
every rehearsal i was thinking to myself
everyone's looking at will the other guy
and he's amazing and people are looking
at me and thinking that i don't know
what i'm talking about and then i
realized actually that everyone is just
worried about themselves
they're worried about screwing up their
own lines and how they're doing they're
not looking at me and thinking that
guy's got no experience they don't even
know i have no experience
and so it was a big kind of gotcha
moment for me that was like oh wow all
of this time i've been worrying about
what other people are gonna say about
the fact that i don't know how to do
this thing
but actually no one cares and that was
very liberating and i think that was
that experience catalyzed me spreading
out into more kind of content on my
youtube channel because initially it
started off as very much sticking to my
lane just talking about medical school
but then i was like you know what i can
just branch out to the things that i
enjoy people generally are worried about
themselves if they learn something from
it then fantastic and if not then i
don't think anyone's going to care and
so
i think that was the experience that's
probably made me grow the most so just
to highlight for what you said for for
the audience is that the things we're
proud of are generally one we wanted
them and i think that's actually the
hard thing to figure out in our lives
and our channel our wants change but
figuring out what you want so you wanted
freedom from this doctor job that's what
you sounds like you really wanted and
the second part is that it's hard like
i've gotten things like i just got some
investment i just teachable.com they
sold and i got some money and i was like
i don't have to do anything
um
which it's not you're not proud of that
like i'm proud of them but we're proud
of the things we actually had to work
for which is a little counter-intuitive
or it's not as obvious potentially and
so i think that's what's interesting
about pride in the growth part what you
said is you're uncomfortable and being
comfortable it's easy to watch this show
it's easy to read the comments it's easy
to read the book it's hard to get on
stage it's hard to ask for the coffee
challenge i would love anyone if they're
down to do the coffee challenge to post
it in the comments what they do and more
importantly not whether they get the
discount or not but what they learn
about themselves you know i think dr
jovik one of your people was like
they're doing a youtube challenge
they're doing 100 videos inspired by you
i think i would tell them to do that or
go to sendfox.com it's one of the sites
we have start a weekly newsletter and i
challenge you to do that zenfox.com do
your newsletter for 365 days or even
just once a week 52 times and i think
people will learn a lot more about
themselves doing things that
using that discomfort as a compass to
maybe some directions of growth
yeah absolutely all right let's just
bash through some more questions from
talal he says how do you find what
you're good talented at i.e innate
skills unfair advantages that you have
yeah that's it's tough and i think do
you what would you say yours is i think
mine is that i enjoy all this kind of
computer stuff and therefore any time i
spend doing computer nerdy stuff is time
like it doesn't feel like work another
advantage that i have is i've got the
the brand of being a doctor and having
gone to cambridge university which has
some kudos among students around the
world so those are probably my two
biggest things
i think there's a few pieces that you
highlighted and i think that's the right
answer so number one just look at what
you're doing in your free time and so
what you're gravitating towards if it's
music if it's art if it's computers
there's probably something unique there
about finding your skills in that number
one number two that i really like is ask
your friend so ask someone that you
respect don't ask someone that's a bum
ask someone that you're like hey i
admire this person ask them like hey
what do you think my unique talent is
and guess what they'll probably tell you
and you'll be like oh yeah you're right
and three i think you also find try a
bunch of things out to find out what you
don't like yeah that sounds like here's
another challenge too just go text and
help one person so what i mean by that
is that just text someone right now go
on whatsapp go on instagram go on your
text phone i'll do it right now
and if you actually help one person one
it makes you feel more confident but
think about what would i help someone
and what you would help with is probably
your unique skill that you have an
advantage in nice
all right and we have a question from
let's see from any rude rajesh who says
what's your best message to current high
school students what advice would you
give to high school students oh high
school students man what's up yes i
don't know man high school was a weird
time for me i was like i was with like
my
like i was with my elementary school
friends then i was with the jocks and
then i was with the nerds
and i just remember i was very emo man i
was very
like i smoked cigarettes
and i like wore my boy scout uniform to
school because i thought that was cool
and so
kind of it was a weird time i think like
high school as well as college i think
that for me i would just try think of
life as a buffet and try a bunch of
dishes out so try boy scouts try online
businesses try reading clubs like and i
tried a lot of things out and the second
thing i would say is that i was very
lucky that i got born in san jose
california represent the 408 yay area if
anyone's out there but i was lucky that
my classmates
one of them sold their company for a
billion to cisco meraki that's the
company some of them now are vps
at the public companies
and that was the expectation
that was like the and then me
like going to work at intel was like oh
he's going to work at intel out of
college and then you know running a
company that's we're an eight-figure
business at appsumo.com which is amazing
and we love our sumo links and the
customers and that's the norm and so the
point i'm trying to really highlight for
everyone out there is if in your high
school think about who you're
surrounding yourself with because if
you're spending time with like my jock
friends they're nice guys there's
nothing with them but they're now and
this is not as a knock on these
professions but it was never my
aspiration
it was they're electricians and they're
plumbers
and that's great i don't actually my
everyone should do whatever job they
love that's part of one of the things
that really matters to me like i want to
love their work but i knew that i wanted
to be in tech i knew i wanted to be in
in building big companies and be an
entrepreneur and so i tried and i
surrounded myself ultimately with people
that did that like my best friend he's
like a senior developer at stripe.com
and my other friend was one of the early
people at lyft.com and so these are guys
that i went to high school with and i
tried to spend more time with them uh
and less with the people that were
cooler
my friends are cool but like just the
ones that were cool only in high school
nice that's pretty good advice yeah i
think i would fully agree with that i
think in school in college and
university
you've just got so much spare time on
your hands and i don't think we really
appreciate this when we're going through
it but when you start working especially
if you're working like a normal kind of
a normal job like nine to five it ends
up never being nine to five you end up
at work until seven if not later every
day you end up having so much less time
on your hands and so when you're at
school i think really take advantage of
all of that just ridiculous amount of
free time you have and occasionally i i
get messages from people being like hey
when i get home i do my homework and
then it's time for bed and that's just
unfathomable because if you get home
from school like say five you do your
homework for let's say two hours you
still got between seven and eleven to
just do whatever you want and high
school is the time where for example i
learned to code i took myself design i
took on lots of these different hobbies
that now looking back i'm so glad i went
down these rabbit holes because at the
time it didn't seem like it would be
particularly helpful or just like oh
this is cool i'm making like ten dollars
here and they're making a website but
now like those skills compound on
themselves so much over time and you
feel really glad that you spent that
time in high school having said that i
just i did spend about four hours a day
playing world of warcraft for three
years happiest time of my life but
hey now you can make a living doing that
though which is kind of wild yeah that's
true that's true but one thing i want to
highlight though i thought about this
with twitch because my friends work at
league of legends and so forth and we
see people that are twitch people that
make a million dollars that's only the
top ten and so i think the thing that's
interesting there is that you can find
follow your passions so i think people
are asking how do i find my passion try
a lot of things out and find out the
stuff that you're like excited to keep
doing and so with the twitch stuff if
you're not able to make it in the top 10
there's still a lot of opportunity to
start businesses or get jobs in gaming
right like you can start a marketplace
for gamers or you can sell books for
teaching people how to game or you can
do gaming parties there's a lot of
opportunities if you're not in that
thing but for me i think where i've done
success in my career by my own self i
think success is a horrible word by the
way yeah i think it's it's a dirty word
because success is what we tell everyone
else yeah oh ali is successful
this person is successful and i think we
have to decide our own metric
of success uh in this life i think
that's almost one of the most important
things and so for me it's like
when i've chased money and opportunity
i've been less fulfilled i've sustained
it and i've made less money when i just
said hey i really love doing these
things i don't really care how much
money it ends up making i've made the
most money
yeah
my theory for it as well it's like
the first question is is this thing fun
and if it's fun then i'll probably do it
if it's not fun but makes money then i
probably won't i think early on i was
more open to doing things that weren't
fun but that made money but now i
realize actually
especially once you've got some level of
success it just makes so much more sense
to do the stuff that that fills you with
joy as corny and hippy as that sounds i
think that's exactly it man cool we've
got a oh a technical question from tovia
woods who says what platform would you
recommend for blogging or would you just
or just making your own website so i
think especially early when you're
starting out i don't spend any money
that's one of my big premises don't
spend money until you start making money
so what's crazy youtube is free
it's free
so
i think what i would recommend for
someone starting out like i personally i
host on hostgator with a blog i use
wordpress.org what i would do if i was
starting today to build my audience i
would do three things i would youtube
instagram and i would do sendfox.com for
the newsletter here's the most important
thing though you have to do it at least
once a week for a year and you can't
even think about stopping until after a
year then you could start thinking about
what you want to do with it and i think
what most people do and i always joke
about my mom my mom does a watermelon
diet she eats watermelon for a month
okay and
of course she can't eat a watermelon for
the rest of the year because that's just
not healthy and you're gonna end up
dying you're a doctor you know that and
what you have to find is you have to
find something that's enjoyable so you
can sustain it and so generally with
content creation or building your brand
or building your audience i would say
instagram is interesting especially if
you're photos i'm not a photo person i'm
not really even a video person i'm more
of like a words person or a
conversational kind of raw person i'm
not a high production like your video is
my production my youtube stuff is like
just more of me chatting and so i think
find the medium that works better for
your style maybe it's audio maybe it's
written maybe it's photos
and then commit to it weekly for one
year and then after a year i promise
anyone out there will have as long as
you stick for it for a year and you do
it weekly you will have some results
yeah no i fully agree with that
sometimes i get emails from people
saying that hey can you critique my you
know email newsletter or my blog post on
my youtube channel and they've put up
three videos and i usually reply with
some kind of nice variant of okay ask me
again in a year's time once you've made
50 videos and then my advice will start
to make sense because when you've just
made three you're still very much on the
steep end of the learning curve you'll
learn so much just by doing it and
you'll learn far more by just churning
out more and more videos than you will
by me giving you specific targeted
feedback about your existing ones so i
think at the start it's just about
showing up and doing the thing yeah so
two things with that one i one of the
phrases i think about is don't call it
in i think people are like i'm gonna put
up a youtube thing and just get rid you
can't call it in you have to show up but
let me i'm curious for you man when you
started youtube like just like tovia or
i think people were like look at ali
he's got yeah but he started now just
like any of you can he has any of you
can go to youtube and hit that upload
button and start promoting it but what
was your plan when you started it did
you say what was your mindset my mindset
like i've said this in my very first
video i said that i'm just gonna try
this and see what happens i know that my
first 100 videos are going to be
absolutely terrible so the plan is to
just make 100 videos and then start
getting good at them and i said that
worst case scenario this will be a good
memory to look back on and my grandma
will enjoy watching the videos i've got
that from my very first vlog and
actually so when i made the decision
that you know what i'm going to start
vlogging i i i had all this stuff going
through my head about what sort of gear
do i need blah blah blah blah but
through kind of all of the kind of books
and podcasts and stuff i've listened to
i knew that was the wrong way to go so i
literally took out my iphone flipped it
over and
lying on my bed
i spoke to the camera and then that
night i put it into premiere uploaded it
that that same evening and that was vlog
number one and i think had i worried
about making it good
i wouldn't i would have never done it
but just putting something out there
builds the momentum builds the flywheel
and then you get going so one of my
favorite quotes that i think about is
momentum begets momentum and then it
brings on stuff so how did you keep
going though were you getting results
were you getting a lot of views right
away was it like oh my god because you
also said that you're like you had to
detach from the view count so i'm
curious yeah you sustained it now over
the years so at the start i was very
much focused on the view count i'd be
refreshing the youtube studio or the
youtube app like 18 times a day and be
like oh
i've now got 71 subscribers rather than
70. oh we've got two subscribers today
sick this is a great day and i'll just
be doing that multiple times a day
and then after because after doing this
for
a few months and i started hitting a
thousand two thousand subscribers at
that point i realized that looking at at
the metrics just doesn't make any sense
and actually what i should be doing is
focusing on the process of just trying
to churn out these two videos a week and
just not worrying about the views at all
and this is something that i still
struggle with today i
i want to make videos talking about
fiction books that i've read but every
video i've made about fiction books in
the past is tanked compared to a video
about productivity or you know
something like that i read a lot of
fiction i read a lot of fantasy this is
what i like and so i want to i want to
have the freedom to make those videos
without worrying about what the stats on
youtube studio are going to say there's
there's actually a theory it's called
the sex cache theory
of it no what is that so i i don't know
where i heard about it or who it came
from but it's like leonardo dicaprio so
he did titanic made a bunch of cash and
then he does like some indie film like
basketball diaries because it's sexy and
so i think there's something there as a
creator where you have to do the videos
that bring in the audience and bring in
the traffic and then you also have to do
the experimental stuff which could be
something that happens in the long term
but also it's just like a little sexy
and a little bit more creative i think
one thing that you you spark to me man
that that i think is really powerful
especially for the audience like adam is
asking some questions and sophia is what
would you work on for free because when
you started this channel how much were
you getting paid oh absolutely nothing i
think that's something that's really
been fascinating for me as i've done
i've gotten more into the content
creation is that i think what people
don't realize like they see these views
they don't realize how much work really
goes into it yeah to be an influence is
just as much work as almost any other
job so i think you have to figure out
what would you work on for free so
whether you're getting paid a lot or a
little you're like well i'm still
enjoying this and i still keep going
yeah i'm big on the phrase of trying to
monetize your passions and i know that
some people rail against this on twitter
they're like oh no it's not that every
passion has to be monetized i'm not
saying that you have to monetize every
passion i'm just saying that if you can
monetize somehow the things that you're
doing anyway then life just becomes more
interesting because then you can
then you get paid for doing the stuff
that you enjoy doing and
i don't know if you feel this as well
but i often find that for example when i
was learning the guitar and i would be
sitting by myself learning guitar or
actually when i when i was towards the
end of high school i started learning
close-up magic so i'd be doing magic
tricks and stuff and every musician who
starts off guinness starts doing tricks
in front of the mirror or in front of
their webcam
but when i started performing in real
life so i used to volunteer at at the
local hospice and do magic tricks for
them once a week and then i had this
paid gig at a restaurant and it was
really scary and completely failed at it
but just having that mindset of okay i'm
now taking this out into the real world
i'm showing it to people and putting it
out there it completely changed the game
because
it's it's so easy to focus on kind of
the moves and the shuffles and the coin
rolls and stuff that no one cares about
because you're doing it in front of your
webcam but as soon as you start putting
out publicly
it just
it makes it more fun because you've got
this other element to it but b it really
focuses down the things that you're
weakest at and the things that you need
to improve for it to actually make a
difference in the world why i say that
is that when it comes to monetizing your
passions i think trying to make money
off of baking cakes yeah sure
if you want to bake a muffin then that's
absolutely fine but if you want to bake
them off in and then try and sell those
muffins it just it just adds another
dimension of fun to the whole process
yeah if you're trying to rise up and
maybe you you don't have the job you
want maybe you don't have the career you
want maybe you're trying to figure out
your passion look at the person that's
probably doing the thing that you admire
and
i'll be very specific go work for them
for free
and so how do you work for them for free
let's just take ali ali is telling you
about close-up magic ali is telling you
his youtube channel is important ali is
telling you he's working on other
businesses i would email ali or me or
whoever's life you imagine is living the
life that you want to learn from and
email them value so what is value email
is saying hey ali i know that this is
important to you plus your channel has
changed my life here's three things i
think you should be doing that maybe
will help you i'm happy to do that for
free if you'd like me to if not no hard
feelings ps keep doing amazing work and
so
that is what like the people i've hired
at our company like mitchell who helps
me with all of the okay dork.com stuff
he volunteered at my i do a charity bike
ride he volunteered he's like hey i know
this you're doing a ride i want to just
help out for free and then from that now
he has a full-time work that he loves
and he gets paid really well and so i
think it's interesting and then you go
work for those people maybe you're like
man i hate these people or i hate this
type of work but at least it helps you
understand what you don't like so you
can get to the things you do like so
have you got a process that you go
through to set goals and i'm asking
selfishly i guess you're familiar with
the jason freed and dhh approach to
goals like the whole base camp spiel
seems to be that we don't really like
setting goals goals are arbitrary why
would you bother
taking this number that you've made up
out of thin air why would you take that
seriously and instead they seem to say
that it's more about just focusing on
just trying to make a good product and
have fun while you're doing it and serve
the community and stuff and i find that
i resonate with that quite a lot i've
got this business mentor who always
encourages me to set numerical goals for
my youtube channel and i always feel
that uh what's the point why my goal is
to hit a million subscribers by 2020
it seems very arbitrary how do you think
about goal setting because i'm i'm
really not sure on this front okay so
you're where are you in the uk right now
i'm in cambridge
you're in cambridge it just sounds so
cool when you say it man and if you were
gonna if i was gonna say ali go to
france what how would you figure that
how to get to france just like
directionally oh i'd go on google maps
and figure it out
okay so i think what the 37 signals guys
are saying is let's say you're in
america and you want to get to mexico
they're like just drive south and
eventually mexico's down there and if if
you don't hit it just keep going south
until you do
and so
i've observed three systems of setting
goals
and i think each of them can work
so i think there's the object oriented
goal which is what is my objective so i
want a million subscribers so for
appsumo our company we have a revenue
goal we want to get extra millions of
dollars in revenue this year very
objective and you'd have sometimes have
to have a destination mexico revenue
so then i think there are process i
think there are progress goals so a
progress goal
is so another example is like my mailing
list so like send fox.com my mailing
list i don't care if i get one so and
what's important about goals is they
have to matter to you so a progress goal
is i don't care if i get one new active
subscriber a month or a thousand it
doesn't change for me the value so a
progress goal to me is is it progressing
and i get five i'm happy if it's
negative i'm not and so that's a
progress goal and the last one is the
system goal so a system goal is i'm
going to go to the gym three times a
week that's it that's my system there's
not a progress but i will be there three
times a week and so i think each of
those goals work in different scenarios
and different things so it's i don't i
wouldn't say absolutely that 377 was
wrong i think in business
i i think you have to know how things
are performing or progressing so we
generally do
our whole system in there we call it a
gmo but i think there's other goals
where you don't want to have that
because for me like youtube if right now
i'm at fifty thousand and if i said i
want a hundred thousand honestly it
would kill my motivation and i don't
care if i get a hundred thousand or if i
get fifty one thousand i'm just enjoying
what i'm doing so it's more of like i
all right i wanna put out three videos a
week or two videos whatever that is and
each one is a different tool at a
different time okay yeah that makes
sense i think that's the
system's goal is very much how i think
about my youtube channel the only thing
we're aiming for is to get one video out
a week or two or three depending on the
week and if we can make these videos a
bit better over time if the numbers can
be trending in the right direction then
that's all that really matters and i
don't really have a sort of subscriber
count goal because as you said i think
it would take a lot of the fun out of it
because i feel like if i did set out to
get a million subscribers by 2021 i'd be
doing things that prioritize getting
views and that might not necessarily be
the same stuff as what i'm interested in
so for example if that was a goal i
wouldn't do any books about fiction
i wouldn't do any videos about fiction
books because it doesn't tie in with
that particular goal but i guess i do
have goals in other domains like for
example
if i'm setting out to do like a new
business venture or something i have
this bar in my head that i want this
thing to make at least five hundred
dollars a month and i do what it takes
for it to make at least 500 a month and
beyond that if it makes a thousand two
thousand at that point i don't really
care provided it hits that 500 a month
thing
and i think i suppose that's to the
extent to which i have that sort of goal
yeah i think that's great man i'll tell
you for me when i launched my podcast
three years ago i went i set a goal
before i really do anything and i think
what's really important and this is
really important it's really easy to get
what you want but it's hard to know what
you want i'll say it again and i'll say
it the opposite way it's really hard to
know what you want
but it's really easy to get it when you
know it i believe every single person
out there that's watching and listening
i believe in every single person here
can do it but i think we need to spend
more time thinking about what we
actually really want because then you're
like like one year for appsumo i wanted
a million email subscribers and and i i
knew in my heart i was like i don't give
a [ __ ] and so i would spend more time
exploring what do we really want
journaling writing thinking talking and
the second thing so in terms of that is
that like i told you my podcast i wanted
a hundred thousand downloads an episode
and by the end of the year i got 30 000
downloads an episode and so i quit
really oh i quit
i gave up because i wasn't at a hundred
thousand and about seven months later i
said well i really enjoyed the podcast
but because i put that pressure on the
goal it killed the motivation for it and
so it's not to say not to have that so i
started up again about seven to nine
months later my downloads now are at ten
thousand an episode i would beg for
thirty thousand
and i changed my goal to say just put
out one episode that you love a week and
now i don't look at my stats and i love
doing the show it gave me the
opportunity to hang out with owen and
with you and talk to the audience and
share this stuff that i know fulfills me
and so i think goal setting could be
dangerous
because guess what 30 000 is actually a
top show but now at 10 000 i'm just as
satisfied but if i would have just
stayed consistent and it adjusted my
expectations
maybe it would be a 50 000 or it would
have been at 100 000. i think what we
imagine we don't realize how long this
is going to go on for we didn't think
like the shows are going to be going or
the work like appsumo and sumo group our
company i did not think i'd be doing
this ten years later i thought i would
make three thousand dollars a month and
live on the beaches of thailand nice
[Laughter]
so i think the point is find the things
that you could do for 10 years because i
said earlier the 10-year rule is true
are you familiar with uh
marquez brownlee the tech youtuber mkbhd
what about him yeah so he was he was on
the y combinator podcast for some reason
and they were interviewing him and he
was basically talking about the 10-year
rule
they asked him like what's the secret to
your success and he was like in in
fairness i don't know man just pick
something and work on it for 10 years
and then it's probably going to be
successful
i was like damn that's such good advice
just pick something anything and just
work on it for 10 years as people like
gary vaynerchuk would say it's all about
patience in the long term start a
newsletter or start a podcast or start
an e-commerce store or start a digital
store there's no rules that's what's
cool about the internet there's no laws
yet yeah like you can't no one's stopped
on youtube and it's free to host videos
yeah
and i think especially those of us who
are in in quite like traditional fields
it feels like for for a lot of things we
need permission
and that's one of the biggest things
that i've learned that actually
no one's
like
we don't need permission if you want to
do the thing then just do the thing one
of the things i've always said about
entrepreneurship is that an entrepreneur
cannot be satisfied and what i mean by
that is that if you're satisfied you
probably don't have any problems that
you want to solve because if you believe
that there was content out there that
was as good at sharing the thing about
notion or productivity or how to study
better which is what you've done you
would have never started it you weren't
satisfied
and
i think that's saying it's also without
not being satisfied you're saying well
do i need permission to start this
who do i because we're trained we're
literally our parents our schooling
everything is you need permission for
this class you need this structure you
need this acceptance you need to raise
your hand like one of my favorite books
about this is called teaching as a
subversive activity it's an older one if
you haven't read that one it's
phenomenal it's like how would schools
be if they weren't treated like
factories and so it shifts a lot of the
thinking around that uh and i highly
recommend it but i think for everyone
out there it's no apologies without
permission
nice yeah
and just get going awesome thank you
very much noah for taking the time this
has been a lot of fun where'd it go yeah
it just completely flies when you
talking about cool stuff and guys like
all the stuff that we've talked about
all the books all the apps all of the
things the the different challenges that
noah was talking about all of this stuff
is on that notion page and there's a
link in the video description along with
links to all of noah's stuff sign up to
subscribe to this podcast it's very good
so subscribe to the email newsletter and
and the blog it's just all like
generally good insights for if you want
to start a business if you're going to
grow a business like all of this sort of
stuff yeah thank you so much for taking
the time noah ollie thank you for having
me every single one of you out there i
love you go to do something for
yourselves today it's been a pleasure
this made my day thank you so much man
all right we'll see you later guys
bye-bye all right so that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are gonna be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye